yasmine belmadi bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france nouvelle
journée de mobilisation donc un peu
partout dans le pays
cette proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale quel est votre avis il faut la
supprimer
comme le demandent les manifestants au
contraire vous jugé nécessaire de la
maintenir ou en tout cas en partie pour
moi le vrai sujet c'est que actuellement
on a déjà tout un tas de lois qui
servent à mettre à la fois la protection
des policiers et en même temps la
sécurité en avant ces lois ne sont déjà
pas appliquée donc avant de rajouter des
lois aux lois existantes il faut déjà à
commencer par appliquer les lois qui
sont déjà et qui existe déjà et par
ailleurs c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup
de l'article 24 mais il ya aussi
d'autres articles notamment l'usagé de
drones et d'autre d'autres articles qui
qui peuvent prêter à polémique est
effectivement le problème le vrai
problème c'est que actuellement on veut
soi disant renforcer la sécurité et on
met en avant l'argument de protéger les
policiers mais finalement on se rend
compte que les policiers sont vite jeté
en pâture
dès qu'il ya un événement médiatique je
parle notamment des événements de la
semaine dernière ou quels que soient les
actes des policiers ils doivent être
traités jugés etc mais surtout pas jeter
en pâture est discrédité par par le
gouvernement pour en faire un exemple
je lui ai d'ailleurs on voit
actuellement oui oui justement
protection délibère des policiers d'un
côté défense des libertés de l'autre il
est ou pour vous le juste équilibre
mais le juste équilibre et gay déjà dans
l'application de la loi actuelle bien
sûr les policiers doivent rendre des
comptes
et il faut surtout éviter aux politiques
de d'utiliser des événements comme des
comment dire delà de la pole de la
publicité et des exemples je parle des
encore une fois des policiers la semaine
dernière ce qu'ils ont fait doit être
examinée juger par leur hiérarchie par
les tribunaux et il a justice doit être
faite mais en aucun cas tout cela ne
doit être utilisée pour justifier une
quelconque action politique est par
ailleurs la mise en place d'une plate
forme voilà on nous dit on peut on va
les révolutions d'un côté et fait voilà
et de l'autre côté on met une plateforme
pour dénoncer éventuellement les
agissements des policiers
on va y revenir dans quelques instants
justement mais avance on continue sur
ces manifestations un contre le projet
doit sécurité globale manifestations
également pour les droits sociaux on a
entendu il ya quelques instants
notamment un gilet jaune
comment est-ce que vous la comprenez
cette convergence des luttes aujourd'hui
gars est il ya quelques années on avait
déjà les jeunes la manifestation et le
mouvement des filets jeunes ont été
cassés par la très grande répression et
aussi par le discrédit qui a été jeté
par l'inter le laisser faire qui arrange
et peut-être le gouvernement des black
blocks et qui du coup rendez le le
message de gilles est jeune peut peu
audible et donc la voilà encore une fois
on a une convergence puisque on parle à
la fois de sécurité et en même temps on
est dans un contexte où le mouvement des
gis les jeunes se justifiait encore plus
maintenant que qu'auparavant puisque
avec le confinement
l'économie a été très touché et
notamment je pense aux petits
commerçants aux petites entreprises aux
professionnels que ce soit du spectacle
de la restauration enfin bon on ne
compte plus le nombre de professions de
touché et le désarroi est encore plus
important maintenant qu'il y a deux ans
et à côté de ça la priorité semble être
de rajouter et noah source
la sécurité s'ils ont pu dire alors
qu'on a déjà tout un arsenal législatif
qui est en place et qui n'est pas
appliquée alors on a vu un dans au coeur
de cette manifestation n'a vu il ya
quelques minutes quelques tensions qui
commencèrent à se faire sentir on se
souvient des heures de samedi dernier
des violences quasi systématique et en
marge des manifestations
certains s'interrogent sur
l'impossibilité des forces de l'ordre et
repérer les fauteurs de trouble
finalement qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous moi je ne jette en aucun cas
l'opprobre sur les forces de l'ordre qui
sont sur le terrain ce que je condamne
c'est plutôt les ordres et les contre
ordres qui sont donnés par ailleurs
archi et les décisions qui sont indiqués
par qui sont plus gouvernée par deux
politique que par l'intérêt que ce soit
de la population ou des policiers et du
coup on voit lors de ces manifestations
où il ya des violences envers les forces
de l'ordre de l'autre côté il peut y
avoir aussi certaines forces de l'ordre
qui commettent des dérapages et tout ça
contribue à créer une dissociation entre
la police et la population et qui rend
encore plus difficile l'exercice de
maintien de l'ordre par la police alors
il ya swing benzema vous restez avec
nous à vous retrouver un peu plus tard
dans ce journal
ces manifestations également se passe
dans un contexte de vives tensions et
c'est dans ce contexte justement qu
emmanuel macron a décidé de s'adresser à
la jeunesse on en a vu beaucoup 1 qui
participent aux manifestations
aujourd'hui pendant plus de deux heures
et quart le chef de l'état a guère
répondu aux questions des journalistes
du média en ligne brut
un exercice inédit au cours duquel
emmanuel macron a été interrogé sur les
récents faits d'actualité premier sujet
évoqué celui des violences policières
survenues fin novembre à paris
il a aussi été question de l'identité
des jeunes issus de l'immigration ou de
certaines difficultés liées à la crise
sanitaire en voici un extrait il ya de
la violence dans la société
il y à du racisme dans la société
aujourd'hui en france c'est un fait
et donc comme on a une police qui est à
l'image de la société
et bien il y a des manques de la police
qui ont des comportements violents qu'il
faut pouvoir traquer et sanctionner
il ya des membres de la police qui ont
des attitudes racistes qui sont pas
acceptables mais est ce que pour autant
et la police après est-ce que est ce que
pour autant c'est l'institution qui
laissait l'ensemble des policiers non et
donc ce qu'on va mettre en place à
partir de janvier prochain
ces deux choses d'abord un grand sondage
comme l'ont fait les britanniques et
souhaite racisme avait proposé
d'ailleurs il ya quelques mois et on a
trop tardé à le faire et il avait raison
un grand sondage à partir de janvier sur
une plateforme internet où les gens
pourront aller dire en quoi ils sont
discriminés et où il ya le contrôle au
faciès
il ya le logement il ya l'emploi il ya
des maux quotidiens de la vie la
deuxième chose sur les contrôles c'est
qu'on va mettre en place une plateforme
nationale
avec un numéro d'appel la possibilité de
signaler et suite aux déclarations d'
emmanuel macron sur les contrôles au
faciès lors de cette interview les
syndicat alliance police et unité sgp
police appelle les forces de l'ordre ne
plus effectuer de contrôle d'identité
ainsi qu'un de plus procéder à des
interpellations dans un communiqué unité
sgp police déclare je cite notre
meilleure action sera l'inaction regarde
ce soir emmanuel macron accusent les
policiers d'être responsables des
décisions des politiques des 50
dernières années
vous décidez de discriminer et de
couloir et en banlieue des populations
puis nous le fait payer
non ça ne se passera pas comme ça
annonces présidentielles la défiance de
l'état vis-à-vis des policiers non la
police nationale n'est pas raciste et
elle ne choisit pas sa délinquance
monsieur emmanuel macron c'est honteux
le président aura la police qu'il mérite
une interview qui a également provoqué
beaucoup de commentaire chez les
politiques regardez à maquereau créé un
numéro vert de plus police justice et
puis tout ça c'est réglé c'est pas un
gouvernement c'est une plateforme
téléphonique
oui mais le numéro et vers le climat
aussi est sauvé par les arabes
c'est une chance pour la france c'est ce
que m'a qu'on refuse de voir c'est que
la longue va au delà de la diversité
linguistique elle constitue ici un gage
d'enfermement communautaire sur brut
macron découvre l'existence des
violences policières qu'il n'y ait
depuis trois ans sa réponse
retirez la sécurité globale réformer
l'igpn revoir la formation et la
doctrine d'emploi de la police
mais non bien sûr un numéro vert contre
les discriminations emmanuel macron dit
tout et son contraire il faut renforcer
l'identité française mais aussi changer
les programmes d'histoire se précipiter
dans un vaccin incertain tout en avouant
que celui ci changera d'ici avril
les français ont besoin d'une vision
claire avec ses plateformes délatrice
macron instaure un régime de délation
alors que pour les plaintes
il y a le procureur si j'étais policier
je me sentirais bien seul avec macro
comme président et yasmine bentele maths
conseillère régionale d'île de france
est avec nous pour parler de ces
manifestations qui ont lieu
actuellement partout en france notamment
à paris mais aussi pour revenir sur ses
propos du chef de l'état emmanuel macron
on a entendu un des policiers en colère
après la prise de parole du chef de
l'état sur la question du contrôle au
faciès est ce que vous la comprenez
cette colère des policiers aujourd'hui
oui ça à comprends tout à fait cette
colère des policiers parce que à la fois
on leur demande de d'effectuer de plus
en plus de contrôler notamment la vue au
travers de de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et des contrôles de déplacement de la
population on n'a plus le droit de
sortir librement comme on veut soit
et d'un autre côté on leur demande de ne
plus contrôler telle ou telle personne
et on les accuse en fait c'est comme
s'ils étaient accusés de fête et de
principe avant même d'avoir commis des
actes répréhensibles qui somme toute les
policiers sont aussi des êtres humains
et je suis loin de justifier ses actes
je les condamne tout autant que la
plupart des gens mais on ne peut pas
mettre dans le même panier tous les
policiers qui est la plupart du temps et
c'est de faire leur travail correctement
et qui sont de plus en plus lâché par
par le gouvernement on a l'impression
encore une fois et enfin on doit encore
une fois le en même temps des manuels
macron c'est en même temps on veut
renforcer la sécurité le pouvoir des
policiers et en même temps on lâche nos
policiers et on jette le discrédit sur
eux et sur leur action alors un grand
sondage annoncé par le chef de l'état un
numéro vert également voulu par emmanuel
macron pour permettre de faire la
lumière sur tous ces contrôles
vous en pensez quoi de ces mesures
encore un numéro vert ce sera surtout
pour moi des effets d'annoncé pour
tenter de contenter tout le monde les
pros police les antipolis ceux qui se
sentent discriminés par la police et en
même temps avec
la loi de sécurité essayer de satisfaire
ou de dire aux policiers que finalement
ils ont ils auront plus de pouvoir et
+22 marge d'intervention donc finalement
rien de nouveau avec ce gouvernement si
ce n'est encore une fois un cumul de loi
d' annonces d'effets d'annoncé qui ne
sont pas suivis d actes et qui crée
encore plus le malaise que ce soit dans
la population comme vis-à-vis des forces
de l'ordre ce qu'on peut noter cet
après-midi dans le cortège
c'est la présence de beaucoup de jeunes
on voit des visages de deux jeunes
adultes au coeur du cortège
emmanuel macron en s'adressant aux
médias brut a voulu parler aux jeunes
l'exercice il a été réussie il a été
entendu par cette partie de la
population
bah écoutez moi je pense que si les
jeunes sont dans la rue
peut-être que le message a été entendu
mais il n'a pas été acceptée puisque les
jeunes se mobilisent et je pense et je
suis contente quelque part que la
jeunesse aussi prennent conscience des
choses que je sois d'accord pas d'accord
sur les modalités de manifestations je
comprends tout à fait difficulté le
désarroi de cette jeunesse qui est avec
en plus cet état d'urgence sanitaire le
manque de perspectives
finalement se sent délaissée et en a que
pour comme seule solution démocratique
de manifester de manifester son
mécontentement envers ce gouvernement
que ce soit sur la loi de sécurité mais
plus au delà de cette loi de sécurité je
pense que cette manifestation aussi
c'est là comment dire c'est là c'est
l'illustration du désarroi de la
population qui finalement a le droit
quand même de manifester parmi toutes
ces restrictions que l'on subit
actuellement et qui du coup profite de
l'occasion pour montrer son
mécontentement
peut-être ce moment que d'espoir envers
l'avenir puisque finalement les
universités les universités sont
contraintes on ne peut plus vivre sa
jeunesse comme on le veut je comprends
qu'il y ait un contexte sanitaire mais
c'est vrai qu'en france on à la
réglementation la plus restrictive parmi
les pays d'europe et du coup tout
s'accumuler
au manque de perspectives économiques
fait que les gens sont dans la rue
alors pour revenir à cette loi sécurité
globale des rapporteurs de l'onu
on demandait une révision en profondeur
de cette proposition de loi
vous l'entendez comme un signal fort
très fort lancé au gouvernement
oui que que ce soit l'onu qui est
organisme attaché à l'onu qui qui donne
des préconisations à l'état français
pour revoir cette loi
ça montre bien que au delà nos
frontières la proposition de loi choc et
qu'elle contient des éléments qui
méritent d'être revus pour moi en soit
je pense que c'est plat n'a même pas
lieu d'être puisqu'il ya déjà des lois
appliquées comme je vais dit auparavant
et qui ne sont toujours pas appliquées
en tout cas on l'a vu tout à l'heure ses
images de tension une nouvelle fois au
sein de cette manifestation alors
moindre certes que celle de la semaine
dernière mais on sent quand même un
climat très tendu
finalement avec ses hommes
ou ces femmes en noir avec leurs
capuches on en a beaucoup parlé un tout
au long de la semaine
est ce que finalement ça ne dénigre pas
aussi les revendications des
manifestants la présence de ces casseurs
bien sûr et on peut encore se demander à
qui profite le crime
d'ailleurs une syndicaliste assez connu
deux syndicats de police qui est malgré
son devoir de réserve a dit avoir à demi
mots qu'elle soupçonnait aussi que ces
blacks blocks était utile on va dire au
gouvernement pour discréditer les
mouvements de contestation et on ne
suffit pas d'être enfin on ne se limite
pas à la vie de cette syndicaliste mais
c'est la vie qui est partagé par
beaucoup de monde
merci beaucoup et yasmine belmadi
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle vous êtes conseillère régionale
d'île de france